[Music]
well speaking of hunting for blood
she did an interview with nbc speaking
of hunting for poop yeah she did an
interview i'll play a little highlight
then we'll play some of the interview
but so far this is my favorite snippet
it's a couple pieces
in the closing arguments the depth
lawyer said
called your testimony the performance of
a lifetime and said you were acting
what do you say to that
says
the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers
she's such a bad actress by the way but
can i real quick yeah
at any point
when you saw the movie edward
scissorhands yeah
did you ever say
oh my god did they replace johnny depp's
hands with scissors no cause i'm an
adult and i understand that acting is
make-believe
okay just want to make sure we're all on
the same page cause i never at any point
thought oh my god johnny depp
has scissors for hands how did they do
that
she is
not a great actress right no
she rehearsed that
she rehearsed that yeah
oh that was her
that was her mic drop moment and it was
it was a mouse for it that was her
after doing it in the mirror 20 times
that morning they're gonna ask me about
this and then i'm gonna go oh yeah the
one who convinced the world he had
scissors for hands but i'm gonna do it
like
really
seriously
she's a bad actor like
johnny depp
would have absolutely been [ __ ] in
this trial
if he had plunged his dick into a good
actress
the only thing that saved johnny depp is
the fact
that he [ __ ] a really hot not even a
really bad actress a me a medium a mid
actress winona writer would have pulled
this would have pulled absolutely would
have had us all who would have been like
oh my god what did he do to her
but she's terrible she's really bad yeah
really bad
in the closing arguments okay
so that was a little snippet it finally
came out
the whole thing
since the verdict
as you sit here with me now
has it sunk in
can you imagine i was thinking about
this when i was i was watching a little
bit this earlier today
for this for the show i was just saying
let me see what's in this and trust me
there's stuff that's worth it in here
but
can you imagine if it was a dude that
was accused of doing what she did to him
do you think nbc would be doing be
having her on the news the next him on
the news the next day like he would be
completely ostracized he would be on
like
infowars yeah exactly trying to tell his
side of the story he'd be on a stream
with jack posobiac
or jack murphy newsmax or jack murphy
jack murphy
how could it
surreal oh you know what the best thing
about this interview is do you know what
a bunch of legal experts are now saying
is that johnny depp right now is in a
position to sue her again of course that
he could technically
they don't know if he'd win or not but
there are already lawyers coming out
saying because of this interview and
she's tripling down
she could absolutely sue her again it's
like if i said royce is a pedophile
right and royce eventually goes stop
saying that i'm going to sue you and
then he sues me i win he wins in court
and then you keep doing it and i just go
on nbc and go yeah well
he might have won that court case but at
least i'm not a pedophile they'd be like
you just
lost the case what are you doing her
lawyer is we know her lawyers back
because we saw it but
wouldn't the first thing the lawyers say
is shut up about this is what i would
say look johnny's already said he's not
gonna call you for the 10 mil he's going
to he's going to wave it he doesn't want
it he just wanted his name clear so look
you're out 10 mil don't worry about it
do you want to push this guy so he calls
you for the 10 mil is that really what
you want to do listen honestly you made
out like a bandit guess what way to
listen in the two years you could be
making a netflix movie as your lawyer
[ __ ] as your lawyer i shouldn't be
saying this right now but i'm starting
to [ __ ] believe johnny depp yes
having to deal with you for the past
year
i feel abused
so
just put a sock in it and what was that
doing a [ __ ] bump on the stand what
are you [ __ ] nuts what is wrong with
you look honestly we're not on trial
anymore so i'm not gonna hold my tongue
anymore
you're [ __ ] lucky that you got this
is what happened do you understand we're
all hollywood lawyers we were all doing
bumps at the trial but some of us were
doing it like [ __ ] grown-ups hey i
explained to you what perjury was like
four times and you did it anyway do you
think you did it anyway do you think
johnny wasn't doing coke in the [ __ ]
courtroom you [ __ ] yeah he was doing
it in the bathroom but he's a pro during
the recess dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] retards
everyone's tired of this [ __ ]
everywhere every human people even
people that
there's like four people that still
support her i think but even they're
like
head up
and
difficult
in part yes
this has been
a long time coming do you stand by
your testimony and your oh my god
this one's setting her up
setting her optimally [ __ ] a lot of
people don't know but i used to [ __ ]
johnny that back in the day we're still
friends
accusations against johnny depp about
abuse of course you imagine [ __ ]
johnny depp [ __ ] katie kirk back in the
day like in her prime and that's why
she's just like let's get this [ __ ] by
the way i love you johnny did you what
word is this true or not but it seemed
at least a couple places that apparently
disney's already pulled the dump truck
up full of money for him to come back
and do pirates
can you imagine the first day you're
getting that phone call from hey john
boy what's going on man hey listen
it's kev over at disney listen um
so it's been weird i get it bro but you
know we had to do what we had to do call
me man don't have to commit to anything
now let's have a lunch they're all
trying to let's go easy we can't just
jump on them right now question was
kevin a name you made up or are you
referring to kevin feig the actual
person that would be calling him
would be kevin feige
no i swear to god it would be kevin
feige hey
i want you to know right now man that
the entire time this was going on i was
over here fighting for you yeah man when
they fired you bro
i was your advocate i was somebody's
giving them a paul heyman sketch right
now i was they might have to hire paul
heyman to sell johnny depp on this
because that role was made for you
johnny
no one else can play jack absolutely do
you think i want charlie sterrone in
this role i don't i do not understand
why former ucw napoleon is my home
he's yelling at me
buying day will stand by every word of
my testimony
the real-life drama of the defamation
case between amber heard and her
ex-husband johnny depp captivated
millions of people around the world and
made a bunch of streamers millionaires
yeah
which by the way i'm glad
and made nick ricketta another like 16
mortgage payments
[Laughter]
it got nikrikata a swimming pool
it's the trial that made nick cricket
say quote now i'm not reading super
chats less than a hundred dollars
back to you steve
[Laughter]
amber just got exposed johnny you hit me
this is so cringe
i love that it was
women making fun of it was a lot of
women making fun of her with clips
spreading across social media like
wildfire
i think vast majority of this trial was
played out on social media i think that
this trial
is an example of that gone
[Music]
haywire gone amok and the jury is not
immune to that you think the jury saw it
how could they not i think even the most
well-intentioned juror
it would have been impossible to avoid
this
yeah i know it's almost you shouldn't
[ __ ] on people's beds and [ __ ] cut
their fingers off
i feel like that's like a big part of it
well then not only that i mean can i
take a step otherwise it's almost like
you should not do that stuff and then
when they still just leave you
and you know
go their separate ways peacefully try to
ruin their life probably shouldn't go
around telling everybody how abused you
were
good call i mean i feel like
she got away with the finger cutting and
the bed pooping because she just wanted
to move on she just wanted to move on
and you couldn't you couldn't help
yourself just not only was it no you
just abused him and he left then you had
to go around telling everybody
johnny used to beat me daily it was
horrible
he would hit me with a sack of oranges
it didn't leave bruises
people online and chris she's [ __ ]
crazy insane
look at do you think that maybe he just
had better lawyers i will say his his
lawyers did certainly a better job of
distracting the jury from the real
issues for some people so
hold on translation
so he had better lawyers that's a
lawyer's a good lawyer johnny cochran
was great at distracting the jury you
mean the more famous guy had a better
lawyer the guy with more money
by the way you know kevin nash is
starting a new podcast with sean oliver
really yeah
and i'm really looking forward to that
show because we better get some goddamn
amber heard stories anywhere yeah
frankly disgusting
licker of me one night man but
he's still [ __ ] her and then they're
like then i don't think he will if he's
still [ __ ] her
that's true i think he might be one of
them sean oliver is very funny so i'm
hoping he slips in hey how did you book
yourself to [ __ ] amber hurt
and don't have much sympathy
for either one of you
i don't think kevin nash is still
[ __ ] this [ __ ] by the way i love
that she just asked i got to give her
credit she goes what about all those
people that don't have sympathy for
either one of you and that's a really
good question but i that's how i felt i
know i mean because johnny's kind of a
garbage guy too but you know but look
they're both garbage people but it just
works but if you were going to make me
decide on who's a bigger garbage she's
definitively worried she is worse than
her johnny probably got drunk probably
screamed probably said do you know who
the [ __ ] i am i am sure he did all that
but you know what he didn't do he didn't
[ __ ] in your bed he probably [ __ ] in his
own bed several times
but it's his bed and he could [ __ ] in it
understand that
absolutely
i would not blame the average person for
looking at this and how it's been
covered
and it's not what she did marsh
that's how it's been it's how it's been
covered
i hate the way they covered it
not think that it is
hollywood brats at their at their worst
i'd
but what people don't understand is it's
it's actually
so much bigger than that
it's so much bigger than that rice
these are the people that sing imagine
and think they're healthy this is the
front lines of the culture war going on
these are the most out of touch [ __ ]
right like
they are the most
disconnected from reality people
like we always talk about it i know it's
a joke and it's ongoing but if you go
how much do you think a gallon of milk
and milk is i don't know a hundred
dollars yeah yeah they have no clue they
they don't understand
what gas hike
these things don't affect me what is gas
yeah there are people right now that are
can't drive to the shelter that's giving
away baby formula because it's run out
all right
right now listening having to listen to
this woman [ __ ] about how her
millionaire boyfriend screamed at her
dude do you know how many of these
people at this level of fame don't even
have driver's licenses
right they don't even know it's it's
literally they don't even know how to
drive a car to show
there's just people that just take you
everywhere and go get your things and
you just stand around and everyone
brings you your breakfast and they like
it's just insane they're eating at the
french laundry while you're eating a
burrito at an actual laundromat yes like
do you understand that you will never
understand what it's like to be a normal
human i don't know man laundromat
burrito sounds pretty good right now i'm
not saying it's bad hey we got any more
uh laundromat burritos back there fresh
out
starving
this is uh
this is not only about our first
amendment right to speak but here's the
thing about the first amendment the
first amendment protects free speech
it doesn't protect lies that amount to
defamation
whoa whoa push back
wow they really must want to be getting
johnny depp on one of their good morning
shows again and stuff everybody
everybody's going i'm telling you man
you're right that knife's out he's had
[ __ ]
700 phone calls he has 700 voicemails
right now going johnny what's going on
john hear me out fear and loathing too
hey johnny how you doing man listen it's
uh dave over tmz listen i know i called
you a rapist and a woman beater
repeatedly i mean
really just that's all i did really but
hey water under the bridge it's a time
for all of us to move on all right and
build new opportunities
you're like what what's going on
[Laughter]
and that was the issue in the case yes
exactly you can't go into the free
speech does not protect you if you
you know go into a crowded theater and
you scream fire
the basic [ __ ] takes that this basic
[ __ ] has it's so basic
she really is basic everything about her
right
we get the concept of she is a carbon
copy
of every wannabe actress that's working
at a coffee bean in [ __ ] la right now
it's the same basic takes
free speech from the greeks my
understanding of what that means is not
just the freedom to speak
guys
constitutional expert
amber heard
did she just say that free speech
is not the freedom to speak
she invokes just the freedom to speak
but that's exactly what the first
amendment is just the freedom to speak
she's saying well it's not the freedom
of speech so much is my right to slander
people
and make up lies about them in the press
fire why don't the hands look like they
belong to someone else oh because um she
was actually trying to get that really
cool surgery with scissors on his hand
like amber like like johnny depat
but it didn't work out
it didn't take rejected no so they had
to use the hands of a 47 year old puerto
rican man
she was gonna have one of her fingers
she was gonna have one of her fingers
replaced in one of those little jars you
keep cocaine in she does she does she
has like the hands remember remember
remember when charlie's uncle had the
big fake hands on don't look don't look
don't look they'll look
fire we get the concept of free speech
from the greeks my understanding of what
that means i get my concept from jimmy
the greek
amber i can tell you nobody's less
interested in your understanding of
anything
than me
the way i understand shut up
constitutional expert amber heard guys
hey listen uh listen kevin nash's
[ __ ] fleshlight
right
i don't give a [ __ ] what your
interpretation of constitutional law is
you dumb hall jesus [ __ ] christ
it's not just i'll tell you something i
wouldn't be interested in a female
lawyer's opinion of the constitution
much less your opinion of it i don't
want to listen to somebody pulling up in
a 200 000 tesla suv to [ __ ] planned
parenthood do you [ __ ] hear me
you stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] sneaking
james franco into the apartment so she
could [ __ ] him in johnny depp's house
that's the kind of thing where that'll
bro [ __ ] me you couldn't [ __ ] him at his
apartment he should have let's say that
johnny depp
did beat the [ __ ] out of her right
mm-hmm
he should have been cleared just for
that yeah i was gonna say could you
blame me if he did can you even blame
him at this point no if you brought a
dude if you brought a dude back to him
another man you're with
his place and [ __ ] it and then to thank
you and then to thank you she sits in
your bed
dude i mean
at what at what point do you not take
the train to ask whooping city and be
like enough okay i got it i got it you
know
freedom to speak
these hands are rated e for everyone
it's a freedom to speak truth to power
pitch is going to get equal rights and
left
there you go
[ __ ] in my bed again you [ __ ]
eagle rights and left is [ __ ] amazing
the truth is the word yes
i was informed that bird is the word
issue
i'll just come in and interrupt the
interview turn her turn turn is the word
the best would be is if johnny depp came
in singing and doing the dance
she's like what the [ __ ]
where am i
they could do the out of the way you
hear so johnny i heard you're going to
be your newspaper
starts walking away and he's like it's
very good to be
here i'm so glad i could all forgive
each other
oh
and i spoke it to power i also liked it
nbc comes in singing the turd is the
word
nbc news is great they have a very clean
very very clean bathroom to do coke in
all this and more tonight on nbc
nightlist news with lester holt
you know like
what a clown show
with everything going like everything is
being handled so poorly and the world's
falling apart anyway could we get a
little bit of that absurdity please be
[ __ ] amazing i would be happier but
you know what man i'll pay six dollars a
gallon for gas you know i just watched i
just johnny sing the turret is the worst
i want all of life to be i think you
should leave sketch like i'm fine with
that everything should be completely
wrong look we're already at [ __ ]
levels let's just [ __ ] lean into the
[ __ ] level we all want to get to the
bottom
did you see the joe biden one no
somebody so joe biden was talking about
how how you know inflation is going up
and this and that and somebody
photoshopped joe biden's face
we're all trying to figure out
that
the guy who did this
and i paid the price
in the closing argument
you know what it turns out the price was
exactly 10 million dollars
the depth lawyer said
called your testimony the performance of
a lifetime
and said you were acting
what did you say to that there's a piece
of the clip again says
the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers
it's so bad right that's so i'm i feel
douche chills
it's so awkward in here i don't know how
to feel i it's that's douche chills
she really thought that she nailed that
like it's a movie take
if i if this was i'd rather watch the
entire postmates commercial again if
this was a movie i would have to go cut
amber we're gonna we're gonna do that a
couple more times look i know that's
very i know there's a small role but can
we get a better actor
ah yes gordon street
oh my god remember that they just
brought in i remember charlton heston
they brought in [ __ ] charlton hester
to replace the uh gordon street who by
the way probably got half a mill
yeah one 20-minute monologue
that was um
that was two right world two that was
two when they had money so yeah they
probably paid him a fortune that's right
that was when they had that that's when
they had that's when they had cats
i once knew a girl who lived on gordon
street
but that was a long time ago i know this
is a small one i was young
do we have to put up with this
i mean you know can't we get a better
actor i know it's a small part but i
think we can do better than this
has somebody over cut this with the
terence howard uh [ __ ] what's his
face from iron from playing in iron man
because this is perfect for it
because they actually did upgrade with a
better don cheadle is objectively a
better act yes
this stupid scene is so dumb
he's just he was off scene already
why was he already there i once knew a
girl who lived on gordon street
he's all into it long time ago and he
starts crying
not a day passes i don't think of her
promise i made
i will always keep
it makes you go i want to see that movie
what's he talking about the way he
starts tearing up
that one perfect day on garden street
that's uh five blocks up two over
thank you
that's what this ever thing feels like
though
again if [ __ ] johnny had been up like
royce said against winona ryder or
somebody juliette lewis would have had
him buried throw that she should have
buried under the jail chick that plays
kim wexler would have blown her out of
the water oh [ __ ] man
i'm the professional [ __ ] the woman who
played skyler would pete amber heard i'm
honestly thinking marie would have
beaten me i'm thinking of how many
different female actresses would have
probably buried him because it would
have been just mildly better than what
she was
i had listened to weeks of testimony
she's not even a marvel actress she's a
dc actress amber heard is one of those
like people that thinks that
like like she looks at acting
and like
tries to act you know what i mean
whereas good actors don't try to act
they get into a role and they're like
i'm playing this role yeah she thinks
that she does the william shatner thing
where it's like
i'll pause
to make a point and you're like that's
so wooden and she's doing what she
thinks acting is not what acting is
which is scary
she's a caricature
yeah exactly
uh
insinuating that or saying quite
directly that
you know i'm a terrible actress
well so
we know
that's why you lost the case
i i'm i'm a bit confused how i could be
both the depth team argued that you were
the abuser that you instigated physical
violence did you
i never had to instigate it i responded
to it
the interviewer has just completely
dropped any pretext of like oh amber
here it goes so good to have you here
she's like dropped that sweet tone yeah
you're right entirely dude right
she's just this is a trap this is like
that she went she went from puff piece
to frost nixon well you got to be
careful it's katie couric man you got to
be careful she does because she can do
both yeah so you got to be careful with
katie kirk because she can do a puff
piece but she can also just start
punching you in the gut if she wants to
you're living in violence and it becomes
it becomes normal
that's not kidding i testified to i'm
pretty sure right i just thought she's
aged really poorly you said you have a
responsibility quirk
are we sure
i'm no i'm honestly because i know katie
couric aged really badly and i'm
thinking this is oh it's nora o'donnell
i honestly don't blame you
they they look similar right now that
they're when they're younger but now
that they're older they do kind of like
no they're saying it's savannah guthrie
well pick one guys [ __ ] character
some news [ __ ] look some old white news
[ __ ] some news [ __ ] we're not gonna be
asking virgie to pull up pictures of
that's for sure
samantha guthrie from savannah guthrie i
guess savannah yeah wasn't she she did
some other interview we watched where
she was going ham on somebody yeah uh it
was actually
kamala
yeah she's the one that went hard and
then at kamala harris on kamala started
getting that [ __ ] look yeah
yeah
but there is evidence there are tapes
in which you acknowledge she really is
there are tapes in which you say i
started the fight
i know much has been made of
the things that i said and did i didn't
know i was being recorded at the time i
knew look a lot was made in the trial
about what i said and both said and did
you know what i mean and it's a little
out of control
of these audio tapes they were
first leaked online after being
edited
how were they edited
who what what
what you would hear in those clips are
not evidence of what was happening it
was evidence of a negotiation
of how to talk about that
with
your opinion you literally said yeah i
hit you no one's gonna believe you amber
what negotiation was that amber you're
you're about to get sued again
this is
i mean if i'm johnny depp right now i'm
calling my lawyer and being like we just
do it again
yeah let's bury this [ __ ] in 25 million
in debt
you know if i was johnny depp you know
what i would do
let's go even better
i will forego
the 10 million dollars
if
i get a written in public apology
at this point it's not even good enough
because she's the kind of [ __ ] that'll
write an apology and then immediately go
back and write another piece going like
i only i write that i wrote that under
duress
he had a gun in my head he got a gun in
my [ __ ] there was nothing i could do
and he'd be like now i gotta switch
again
but i am looking at a transcript that
says oh god he says you start physical
fights and you say i did start a
physical fight i can't promise you i
won't get physical again
i mean this is in black and white i
understand context
but you're testifying and you're just
telling me today
look i don't even i don't like savannah
guthrie but savannah is like
i've interviewed world leaders
amber
dude savannah guthrie's literally saying
you're testifying like she's really
trying to get her on the record again
huh you know she should have hired
savannah savannah guthrie to be her
lawyer she would have been better off
okay i never saw her guthrie's just
always had a thing for johnny depp yeah
this is my chance yeah i got him go
fight and here you are on tape she walks
up to him hey johnny so what you know
you're too old for me you're 10 years
older than me johnny johnny you're the
same age you're we went to high school
together
dang you did as i testified on the stand
about this is that when your life is at
risk
not only will you take the blame for
things that you shouldn't take the blame
for but when you're in an abusive
dynamic say narcissist narcissist every
crazy white girl says narcissist
psychologically narcissistic emotionally
and physically
you don't have the resources that say
you or i do with the luxury of saying
hey this is black and white because it's
anything but oh she won't say narcissist
because he's not diagnosed with
narcissism you could sue her for that
too he's she's you know even i mean not
that she's already hasn't there four
times but but when you're living in
babbling yeah
then there are other times there's
another tape where
you're taunting yourself
she has not let go
oh tell the world johnny depp i a man
the victim of domestic violence 20
second clips or the transcripts of them
are not representative of
even what about that dude that they did
the hbo documentary on it was a three
second clip of him pissing in the
bathroom remember that guy what was his
name you know i'm talking about that old
white guy who killed somebody got away
with it then they were doing the
documentary on him
they were doing the documentary on him
and then he went to the bathroom forgot
that he was miked and said to himself i
know you're talking about i'll get his
name somebody in the chat will figure it
out that was a three second clip of him
admitting that he killed her to himself
because he didn't remember he was miked
and he was [ __ ] taking a piss that's
crazy yeah so yeah i also love she's
like oh that 20 seconds isn't
representative of like the whole time
we're together no no it's robert durst
robert roberts robert thank you but like
she's like yeah that 22nd clip is not
representative of the whole situation
and you're like no but it is
representative of that 20 seconds right
so it's like a good point you can't just
edit out 20 seconds good point that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
the two hours are saying look look the
second amendment if you ignore shall not
be infringed yes
those are the three hours that those
clips are excerpt from matt fields
bought a beer amber looks like a
transsexual joe dirt in clown makeup in
this interview
shut up dumbass
samantha guthrie
amber the evidence piled up i mean we
have text messages here
brian's hat is the stupidest hat i've
ever seen in my life
don't do the voice
don't do the voice
god you're right
they didn't say [ __ ] man they didn't say
[ __ ]
just put the whole three hours the guy
at the hat store said i was the only guy
who could pull this look off
who said that
i'm not a lawyer as i tested him no [ __ ]
amber
you're not an actress either then why
did i just pay you a 12 000 retainer i
was for only fans oh no
fight she'll [ __ ] in your bed she'll be
on only fans she should take away this
whole summit oh yeah
you i was
talking in those recordings as a person
an extreme amount of emotional
psychological and physical distress but
not johnny though right
johnny was didn't feel that way that a
crazy chick just [ __ ] in his bed after
[ __ ] james franco throwing a whiskey
bottle at him
he said it doesn't never
hit you savannah never hit the wall like
a [ __ ] rocket crash test yeah she
used to be hot
i
i can't find a pic of her like full body
but i posted one of her face when she
was in college
dude
let's see
oh that was her that one you just okay
and show links
yep okay
look at young
what's up girl
yeah look at the hair
look at the [ __ ] hair
yeah it's terrible is that a lie it's
really showing your age when you have
that kind of what about the witnesses
who said they what about i've seen you
instigate physical violence what about
the video footage what about the
witnesses what about the audio
i've seen what about you punching him in
court
firsthand how people will file rank
and support
amber there was a there was a recording
that said come at me [ __ ] i'll cut you
what did you mean by that no
come at me [ __ ] i'll cut you again
again like i did last tuesday you want
to lose another finger [ __ ]
person they depend on did they all come
in and lie in court
i
this is a
massacre they she i you know what this
means right they're done with her oh
yeah the whole industry
when the knives are out you're done yeah
they're all [ __ ] they're they're all
giving her the [ __ ] jon snow they're
taking turns stabbing her in the chest
and then they're just gonna [ __ ]
throw her out in the snow and [ __ ]
now johnny's back in
by the way and you know that's exactly
why they had like savannah do this
interview not like a guy like a lester
hulk because it made her feel like oh
this is going to be she's a woman she's
going to understand and she did start
like amber how does it feel to now like
well it says on tape that you punched
him well not only that too but this
interview the tone and it would have
just optics wise would have been really
bad
if she's going out crying about abuse
and you just have a man come in and kick
the [ __ ] out of her for 30 minutes
that'd be kind of you know call any of
his witnesses this would have been a
great opportunity for matt lauer to make
a comeback you're right oh he shows up
he's like i'll show you abuse
any names i'm here to just kind of talk
about it from what it felt like for me
as a person who
sat there
yeah so did all of them lie
when i asked his lawyers why do you
think you won and the answer i got was
because she never took responsibility
for anything
she did
she she's a white woman
an attractive one yeah
they don't do that
probably
i'm not making a diagnosis but probably
bipolar
in the marriage
i
did do and say and she's bisexual too
because she she did date a chick for a
while no yeah so you know what she is
she's quad sexual horrible
regrettable things throughout my
relationship uh
i behaved in horrible
almost unrecognizable to myself ways
now she's taking it off of her because
the narcissist that she lived with made
her act made her cut him there's so much
i have so much regret i freely and
openly and voluntarily
talked about what i did i i talked about
the horrible language i talked about
being a bad language that's you know
there's one thing the real centerpiece
of this whole trial has been amber
heard's bad language not the bed pooping
and finger removing
it was the naughty words the extent
where i didn't even know the difference
between
you know um
real wwe champion and kevin nash for
example
couldn't [ __ ] shawn michaels or
something oh no sean michael's [ __ ]
himself already but she's talking about
the bad language like norm and dirty
work you know what the worst part about
this is the disrespect
well no the other part is actually the
worst part but this disrespect is also
not good
right and wrong i
will always scott vulgar says what a
pittance
continue to
feel
like i was a part of this like i was the
other half of this relationship because
can you stop making that weird justin
bieber face
and could be very beautiful keeps doing
this elvis lip girl
herb
what are you one of the kings from
[ __ ] new vegas
i'll need you to six months i need you
to fix my robot dog
leave in los angeles leaving los angeles
welcome to daley wire's newest actress
amber heard
amber hurt and gina karana are going to
be starting at a film she won't even be
taken by them she's done nobody wants
her that's not true
pornography does
yeah for a couple
for a couple of flicks and then you know
what did you oh no vergie
the
the amber heard in pornography oh no you
don't want to see it you don't want to
see your scissor gina carano or
something
that's right i'm i'm proud to announce a
new investment daily wire porn
heading that way why not it's kosher
porn that's right we're doing an entire
media brand all the pornographers ha all
the pornographers have sex through holes
and sheets they're bowling branch sheets
that's right guys daily wirex
coming soon vertical integration folks
it's gonna ruin this country fox i want
to tell you about our new venture daily
wire after dark
daily wire i love that
oh and before anyone asks no my sister's
not going to be on it
nightly wire
there you go boom